anna quiere celebrar su cumpleaños
comiendo pizza con sus amigas por
cuarenta y 2.50 pesos en total pueden
comprar pe cajas de pizza cada pizza
cuesta 850 pesos entonces en total van a
pagar 42 50
y cada pizza cuesta 850 y ahora
selecciona la ecuación que representa a
esta situación por aquí nos ponen tres
ecuaciones pero antes que nada vamos a
entender bien cuál es la situación lo
que vamos a entender bien qué es lo que
nos está diciendo esta oración tenemos
que por un total de 42.5 se pueden
comprar pe cajas de pizza aunque hay
entonces en total están pagando 42.5
aunque yo estoy poniendo a 42.5 en lugar
de 42.50 porque en estas ecuaciones
ponen 42.5 y en realidad es lo mismo
esta es la cantidad de dinero que se
gastaron en pizza y luego nos dicen que
pueden comprar pe cajas de pizza y que
cada pizza cuesta 8.5 entonces una cosa
que podemos hacer aquí es dividir la
cantidad
de dinero que se gastaron en pizza /
cuánto cuesta cada una de esos pizzas o
sea 8.5 y eso lo que nos va a dar es la
cantidad de pizzas que se compraron pero
la cantidad de pizzas que compraron es p
así es que nos queda que esta división
es igual a p
estaré aquí es la cantidad total total
de dinero que se gastaron en pizzas ok y
este de aquí
la cantidad de dinero que se gastaron
por
cada
caja de pizza mientras que pepe está pd
aquí es el número de cajas de pizza
ahora esta no es la única forma que hay
también podríamos ponernos a pensar a
ver cuál es el total de dinero que se
gastaron en pizza y por un lado tenemos
que el total de dinero que se gastaron
en pizza es 42.5 pero por otro lado
también podemos calcular el total de
dinero gastado en pizza como cuánto
cuesta cada una de las cajas de pizza
por la cantidad de cajas de pizza que
compraron y cómo estas dos cantidades
representan la misma cosa las dos
representan el total de dinero gastado
en pizza tienen que ser iguales
esta es la cantidad total de dinero que
gastaron en pizza
esta es otra forma de calcular la
cantidad total de dinero que gastaron en
pizza entonces tienen que ser iguales
bueno y ahora vamos con las opciones que
tenemos que seleccionar hay algunas de
estas que se parezca a lo que tenemos
por aquí pues sí de hecho si esta de
aquí es tal cual lo que tenemos aquí
cierto tenemos aquí 42.5 entre 8.5 igual
a pp que es justo esta opción de aquí
bueno ya ahora veamos si tenemos que
seleccionar algunas de estas también que
hay por ejemplo aquí esta opción de
igual a 8.5 x 42.5 pues como podemos ver
aquí en esta opción que ya seleccionamos
tenemos una ecuación en la que tenemos a
p solita de un lado aunque entonces
sabemos que p es igual a esta fracción
de aquí mientras que esta opción nos
está diciendo que p es igual a este
número de aquí que definitivamente no es
igual a esta fracción de aquí
así es que podemos descartar
directamente esta opción y ahora
analicemos la última opción se parece a
algo a lo que teníamos por aquí pero la
pdi está en el lugar equivocado no
quería estar del otro lado por aquí
tenemos que 8.5 x p es igual a 42.5 no
que 42.5 por p es igual a 8.5 y si
tratáramos de pasar la p del otro lado
del igual pues podríamos dividir entre p
de los dos lados y entonces p / p es 1 y
nos queda 42.5 igual a 8.5 entre p 8.5
entre p pero esto de aquí no es cierto
aunque porque 42.5 es igual a 8.5 por t
no entre p así es que podemos descartar
esta opción también y una cosa que es
muy importante decir en este momento
que realmente no importa cuál de estas
dos ecuaciones se te ocurrió primero
puede ser que hayas empezado pensando en
esta ecuación o puede ser que hayan
empezado pensando en esta otra ecuación
que de cualquier forma siempre se puede
pasar de esta ecuación a esta otra y
viceversa haciendo simples
manipulaciones algebraicas por ejemplo
para pasar de esta ecuación azul a la
ecuación rosa de arriba lo único que
necesito hacer es dividir entre 8.5
porque dividimos entre 8.5 de los dos
lados y tenemos que hacer eso de dividir
de los dos lados para preservar la
igualdad ok y 8.5 entre 8.5 es 1
entonces de este lado nos queda
simplemente p
que es igual a 42.5
entre 8.5 o sea la ecuación que teníamos
por aquí bueno ahora hagamos otro
ejercicio el grupo del señor germán está
vendiendo dulces para recaudar fondos
para la escuela el grupo quiere recaudar
500 pesos vendiendo se cajas de dulces y
por cada caja que venden recaudan 2.75
pesos escribe
una ecuación que los alumnos del señor
germán puedan resolver y que les ayude a
determinar cuántas cajas de dulces
necesitan vender bueno pues hay varias
formas de resolver este problema pero
pues vamos a ver una de ellas
los alumnos del grupo del señor germen
quieren obtener 500 pesos vendiendo
cajas y cada que venden una caja ganan 2
puntos 75 pesos
ok entonces vamos a dividir 500 entre
cuánto ganan por cada caja ósea 2.75
para obtener el número de cajas que
necesitan vender pero el número de cajas
que necesitan vender lo tenemos por aquí
y listo ya terminamos acá y esta es una
ecuación que los alumnos del señor
germán pueden resolver y que determina
cuántas cajas necesitan vender y listo
ahora podemos también ver otra forma y
para eso vamos a mover esto un poco para
acá otra de las formas en las que
podemos resolver este problema es decir
bueno cada que un alumno vende una caja
ganan dos puntos 75 pesos y si
multiplicamos por el número de cajas que
venden aquí lo que tenemos es la
cantidad de dinero recaudado
dado a los alumnos del señor germán
quieren que esta cantidad sea igual a
500 y listo aquí ya tenemos otra
ecuación que los alumnos del señor
germán pueden resolver para determinar
cuántas cajas necesitan vender